good morning millennials
welcome back to the morning toast happy
monday after a long weekend so aka
the hardest day of the year it was i
haven't had like the sunday scaries in a
long ass time mostly because i love my
job and what's there to be scared of 100
it's a vibe and last night was like
truly
sad it was such a sunday but we will
persevere we will get through this
together as a unit because that's what
we do here at the morning
toast get through things because i'm
wearing a beanie and i think that always
brings us together
mrs hat is in is in studio back in the
building this is actually a
shopmorningtoast.com beanie that
everyone has been loving especially me
the statue of my first time one of our
best sellers
one of our best sellers and i just love
a beanie like my hair was nothing
nothing to write home about today and i
and neither was my outfit and i was like
beanie i think a beanie a beanie could
solve all of this
i hope everyone had an amazing weekend
you know what i conclusion i came to
over the weekend
please tell me i think thanksgiving is
my favorite holiday
wow yeah that's beautiful what's not to
love first of all i love
for the only thing that's really like
that it involves to be like an
active thanksgiving participant is to
eat a lot and to be with your family and
like to me those are my two favorite
things in the entire world
core tenants my core values they're like
my one of my
many pillars of society i think that you
have a limited number of pillars as one
does and i think that those are the two
maybe i maybe have like three or four
and those are definitely two of them
don't put me on the spot and ask what
the others are i'm not sure yet
those are that i need more time to think
okay but all i'm saying and i
love the thanksgiving day parade it is
just such a joy
and i love the dog show afterwards so
it's really just like
i never i had never thought about it too
much but i think it's my favorite
holiday
that's so wonderful to hear considering
on our last episode we did a patreon
episode all about thanksgiving and
things you can talk about at the dinner
table with your family
and you said like you kind of [ __ ]
hate thanksgiving no i said i hate the
thanksgiving cuisine
i don't like turkey even though olivia
did make a decent turkey i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna lie it was a little dry
but it was good did you
or did you not feel that tryptophan oh
definitely i was [ __ ] passed the [ __ ]
out by like seven eight o'clock
i definitely believe in the myth of
tryptophan it's not a myth
the myth is real and i have i am a
mythbuster and i have busted the myth it
is true
and olivia was great because olivia made
me like the biggest bowl of kraft mac
and cheese so like that's what i ate
while everyone ate like you know the
cranberry sauce i can't look at
cranberry sauce without like literally
dying it's so disgusting
you know what like fine that's fair fine
fine nobody needs a sauce made of
cranberries
yeah no i mean like it's fine if that's
what it's savagery
if no we won't make you eat it no
definitely not like i won't even touch
it it's so sick and like
it's gelatinous um shape and texture
yeah it's so sick i can't believe people
eat it and olivia and ben were like
this is such good cranberry sauce i'm
like
you two are [ __ ] sick and you need
help yeah no i
i'm glad that you've realized i feel
like this year has like we're really
realizing things about ourselves and
it is the year of realizing things you
realize your likes and your dislikes and
yeah
and you're realizing that thanksgiving
is just it i knew i kind of wish that i
had come to this realization like before
thanksgiving because now it's over and i
have to wait a whole other year
like maybe i'll forget maybe next year
remind me that like i love thanksgiving
so much
but now it's like tis the season and i
think this whole month is really about
those two things
food and family yeah joy and cheer and i
think that
we can bring that to you yeah well it's
really like officially the holiday
season like i walked out of my apartment
this morning and
my door my life was heading up the tree
it was already up my in my apartment
they were setting up the tree and i was
like i've never
been around to see the process and
speaking of trees and updates have you
seen what raqqa fell
rockefeller center tree looks like no
stunning like we said so everyone got
all
clamped for nothing would you say that
it's beautiful stunning
and smart i haven't gotten to know it
personally yet so i'm not entirely sure
but
it might be it might be i'm sure it is
i'm sure it is um we have an amazing
show for you guys because there is a lot
that we need to discuss in the pop
culture world
there's so much to talk about you guys
we we talked about a lot a lot of things
last week but we watched so many things
obviously the undoing finale last night
i have some thoughts i have some
thoughts about the show in general
me too and folklore oh yes i forgot
about that definitely
did you catch a vibe i did you know i
was wait gonna wait till like nightfall
to like really catch five and then by
like three o'clock i was so bored
because we were on vacation i'm like i'm
just watching it and it was still so
premium
lovely i watched it as well it was
literally exactly what you would expect
it was
it was really explanation song
explanation a long pond and a studio
repeat
song explanation repeat yeah exactly um
real house was a potomac which we
have to discuss the record level of
disrespect towards karen huger it was
astronomical that is so funny that you
say that because i was like i watched
the last two episodes yesterday and i
was like the common theme here is that
in every single scene they are
disrespecting karen hugh
making fun of her business her marriage
something making like
they had that sex party where everyone
was like sharing intimidating details
about their sex lives and to everyone
everything everyone else said everyone's
like ooh ah
really no actually what else karen says
something like oh
yeah no it's they're so mean to her so
much disrespect
so on point like when she was like
honestly i've retired my mouth like
you're an old woman i fully respect that
fully respected
when she said to she said a few things
to robin
yeah where she just like sat her down
yeah no i have
and then the whole time people were like
saying stuff to her and she was like i
received that message
and then she said something nasty to rob
and she was like did you receive that
she was just being so on point literally
so much disrespect thrown her way and
she [ __ ] handled it like a queen
so much disrespect i can't take one more
level and even the thing with the hats
like
it hurt when i was coming in it hurt my
heart
it hurt my heart and i just have to say
robin going to
anyone's event about their business and
having the
absolute goal to literally
like mock their business when you
literally run a hat shop out of your
house and you did a photo
photo shoot with your friends for free
in like a junkyard alley
you uh those in glass houses should not
throw stones robin dixon
you literally making fun of anyone's
business is
colossal hypocrisy and i that's where i
stand
i completely agree we'll give you the
full recap after the fast five
actually that's nice to know where you
stand 100 like i'm so [ __ ] done with
robin dixon like i've
i've always been good to her always like
i've always never let her go to that
place of like people i can't stand even
though she's so
deserving of it because she is
legitimately the worst housewife like
girlfriend why are you looking at 1.6
million houses why are you looking at
what would be probably besides monique
the nicest house of all the women
when you are on a payment plan to the
government yeah what are you doing like
who do you think you're fooling not me
not me not me and so it looks like next
week like juan isn't proposing
i don't care i don't care that would be
like
really a crazy turn though yeah i just i
was really disappointing for
uh ashley because she like was playing
on the other side and she's
really had her head on the street and
it's honestly it's the the housewives of
potomac who i don't think are clowns
like they're just fewer and fewer now
just monique and karen
no i'm still here for ashley i think
that ashley
she's not playing both sides but she's
sharing it the all the information she
has
with both sides she's just like an open
book i i can't really blame her
and she wrote that statement and she's
defending the unique when it counts and
when it matters and so
um i'm here for her and i actually i
love her so we will get into that so we
will
but before we get into that we have
other things to get into
such as and i think that we should such
as
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast
and that's true did you lie no
absolutely not
would you ever no no no no no but
you know we have a best-selling
sweatshirt that says rda
it does people are dying the registered
dental hygienists are just felling over
it
as are the toasters and you know the
feeling of rdh i have it right now
because it's that time of the month you
know i'm just got that pain
and i think i know just how to alleviate
it please do alleviate yourself
relieve yourself
today's episode is brought to you by
palmer's the number one cocoa butter
brand
introduces the new hemp oil collection
everyone knows palmer's
i use a chapstick all the time it's the
best actually i don't know if the cocoa
butter is meant to be chapstick but it
is so good on your lips
palmer's new hemp oil calming relief
body lotion and body oil
calms soothes and soothes soothes
calms soothes and hydrates even your
driest skin
with a special blend of 100 natural hemp
seed oil
and skin nourishing cocoa butter for
highly effective skin healing
everyone knows palmer's for their cocoa
butter so now they have it on other
products and it's just like a fabulous
brand and it smells so good
um it's perfect for people with
sensitive skin or eczema prone skin
because it provides dry skin relief with
its powerful moisturizers their hemp
oil body oil soothes irritation boosts
hydration and improves skin texture and
radiance
while the hemp oil body lotion is
clinically proven
to help irritation dryness and itching
you can double up and layer the lotion
on top of the oil for maximum hydration
their oil uh skincare collection is
dermatologist tested hypoallergenic and
safe for sensitive skin
if you want to find any of these
products you can find them in store and
online at walmart target walgreens or
amazon
and the pricing is very affordable the
products are less than ten dollars each
again so if you ever want to shop at
palmer's cocoa butter or their new hemp
oil collection
available available at walmart target
walgreens or amazon
from palmer's choose what's real love it
okay first story
big story last week the grammy
nominations are here we have some big
winners and we have some big
snubs respect was given and respect was
taken the grammys giveth and the grammys
taketh away
they very much do beyonce led the list
of nominees with a total of nine
nominations
she's up to 79 like lifetime nominations
that's crazy
followed by taylor swift roddy rich and
dewalippo with six nominations each
so as the you know the annoying um
resident taylor swift stand i'm very
excited about this
we've had two albums in a row where
taylor has just been like completely
ignored by the grammys that was
reputation and lore
yeah it was like worse than being
ignored because she did get nominated
for
like top performance yeah like such a
such a [ __ ] was the face
we know about your album but we just did
it this is where we placed it yeah
exactly that's so true but folklore now
made it
into all the major categories in one way
or another and it's exciting because
it was it really was given the year that
it was the album of the year like i will
be shocked if anything else wins
i know i feel like she's either gonna
win every category that she's in
or or she's not but i do feel like she
will and after watching the folklore
movie documentary um
and seeing all the stories behind the
songs it makes you appreciate each song
even more of course if i were a grammy
member watching
i it would definitely it would
definitely influence my vote because
having that sort of insight into the
music makes you respect it more and it's
so helpful
to like enjoy yeah i feel like every
year um there's always like snubs
and like the people you know speak out i
do feel like this year that
more artists it's not a ton but more
artists
are now speaking out against the grammys
and i feel like we might one day not
anytime soon
like get to a place where a majority of
artists like are
like don't care about the grammys
anymore yeah because right now like
drake spoke out about it
um the weekend spoke out about it palsy
spoke out about it and halsey's been
very vocal about it she has been um and
those are three like major like drake
the weekend like those are
not you know nobodies yeah that's true
well so here are the nominations for the
big categories if this
amazon ad will get the [ __ ] out of my
face
okay there record of the year black
parade by beyonce
colors by black pumas rockstar de baby
featuring ronnie rich
say so dojicat everything i wanted billy
eilish
don't start now doalippa circles post
malone
savage by megan the stallion that is a
lot
that is a lot you can see all the
categories there are a lot of
nominations i don't know if it's always
like that or we're just like because we
just watching amaze with
three nominees right category it does
feel like a lot
well i really feel like this year was
the year of savage versus say so like
they were both so big on tick tock then
they both had remixes one with nicki
minaj one with beyonce the beyonce one
is
so much better that is what's nominated
for record
that's so interesting yeah and i'm glad
because i think it's so good me too
um i do think that will win you do i do
i think it's going to be a
mighty big sweep for meghan the stallion
in a lot of categories okay she's
undeniably just everything of the sword
i'm taking a different route
i'm saying don't start now by dua lipa
because i actually think it's one of the
greatest songs of all time
me too but i think of it as song of the
year like what got the most play on so
like in all facets i don't know if the
grammys
respect social media or respects the
tick tock of it all but
if you're in the music industry right
now you cannot deny the power of tick
tock no i
i know and i'm keeping that into account
i'm just saying like musically and also
on the charts like don't start now it's
just an exceptional song
and i also think say so and savage are
but i'm just that's where i'm going to
cast my vote i think that dua lipa has
this like very rare disease where she's
unable to put out a piece of music that
is less than less than
stellar no it's it's incredible i would
say maybe my least favorite song of hers
is that new one levitating and it's
still pretty good i don't like it it's
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i got you
yoda starlight
it's good yeah it is you know when i
take it back it slaps
okay album of the year we have a lot of
nominees chilombo by janae iaco
bak pumas by black pumas everyday life
by coldplay to jessie
literally had no idea coleplay put out
an album same volume three by jacob
collier
women in music part three by heim future
nostalgia
same pain
sorry kind ketchup sorry i'm fans
game fans sorry haynes fan
[Laughter]
i i'm not being a g like i just don't
[ __ ] with ham like at all they're like
the opposite of anybody expects you to
i don't really i just don't like they
should be
everything that i love like three
sisters jewish i heard that like when
they first
um started out their band name was the
bagel [ __ ] like i
like i should love them everything they
do bothers me so much like
they're just like aesthetic is the
opposite of what i believe in do you
know what i mean
yes no i know i you don't need to
explain it too okay okay i don't think
anybody's confused okay cool
future nostalgia by jualipa hollywood's
bleeding post malone
folklore by taylor swift one of the last
three i don't think duolepa will get
album of the year post malone could but
i really think it'll be folklore like it
was
i mean i mean i see this every year like
all of every time taylor releases an
album like it is record-breaking and the
numbers are insane and like
usually she sells more albums in that
category than all the others combined
and i'm sure that's the case here as
well
um and i know that that's a big factor
for grammys but it just it was like we
were in a quarantine year and folklore
was a quarantine album like
even if you don't like taylor swift like
you have to admit that yeah
that's true and that would be her third
album of the year because she won for
1989 and fearless i don't know if she
went for anything she didn't win for red
she didn't win for reputation
i i really feel like she's either going
to win them all or just like win none
i wonder if she's going to go well i
mean according to halsey that's how you
that's how you get nominated and that's
how you win and um
now like we can speculate all we want
but we actually know from her
documentary that like the grammys
are really important to her like and
like she had a really good day
last week when she got this because in
that documentary
she got the phone call that for
reputation she did not get nominated in
any of the four major categories
and she was so bummed on the verge of
tears and said i'll just make a better
album and then she may love her and that
one also didn't get any of the
categories so
she maybe is over right now but it's
something that for a while has been very
important to her
yes okay song of the year nominees the
other one was record of the year i don't
know don't get the difference
black parade by beyonce the box by roddy
rich
i just want to leave but that's such a
good song that was like the first song
that literally ever went viral on tick
tock
totally cardigan by taylor swift
really not my favorite song by any means
thank you thank you for your honesty i'm
honest
yeah circles by post malone fabulous
song
don't start now do a lipa everything i
wanted billy eilish
which one is that i don't know all i
know is the new one i think therefore i
am
stop what the hell are you talking about
i actually like
i really do get my pretty name out of
your mouth
i actually like billy eilish but i don't
like when
singers who aren't rappers like talk
it's actually like when taylor talks in
some of her music it's my list of
everything
so he calls me up and he's like i love
you and i'm like please stop talking
like i i hate when people
talk in songs unless you are rapping
that is the
only exception i'm willing to accept so
are you not a fan of sam hunt
i hate when he does that and she was
calling me and i'm like
yeah yeah hate okay hate nothing makes
me cringe more
now we know also nominated for song of
the year i can't breathe by her
and if the world was ending by julian
michaels and jp
if the world was sending no that's like
a very decent like z100 song like when
you're driving five blocks downtown like
by no means is that worthy of any sort
of accolade and that's you know what
justice for [ __ ] halsey like that
song i know that song is a piece of [ __ ]
sorry
halsey has a few songs this year that
like are so [ __ ] good
that song the one that everyone's using
on tick tock to like um it's like a
it's like a trend on tick tock like if
you talk about your trauma you use the
song and it's i want to start the sound
and say oh my god
i gotta get it off my chest i had no
anger got no malice just a little bit of
regret
so [ __ ] good so [ __ ] good and how
dare they julia michael's real like i'm
upset
okay i'm sorry not to pit woman against
woman but here we are
we find ourselves here yet again
okay now nominee's for best new artist
ingrid andres
oh i know i'm so happy she's getting the
absolute respect she deserves
phoebe bridgers chica noah cyrus d smoke
doji
what no osiris
is that it that's even that's even worse
than julian michaels like that's
yeah but yeah that's bad and she's not
like new
and like what did she release one she
has semi decent country
song she knows she has a few hit songs
like with um
you know the djs out there sure
and so like nothing about her is new to
this year
it's just bizarre kate tranada and megan
the stallion
so i think in the stallion cat
oh yeah and i'm throwing ingrid on dress
no literally this entire year is just
like
tick tock no megan the stallion versus
dodgy cat because like their songs just
were both
so big yeah i feel like that's how last
year was like billy eilish verse
liz yeah that's a good call and both
are winning ladies yeah so those are the
big the big nominees the big categories
and so the big snubs
the weekend is most obvious the weekend
and luke combs
yeah is luke holmes's album eligible yes
and he put out
singles this year okay because there's a
bunch of rules like
actually you know you're right because
luke holmes's album came out in november
and he was snubbed that's disgusting
thank you
that is the outrage that's disgusting
and how are we supposed to take the
grammy seriously when they pull [ __ ]
like this
i don't know like sick i know um
and then the weekend is obviously the
most um obvious one he
also like spoke on it posted a little
something on his instagram and it was
just bizarre because he
says that he's been in talks with the
grammys the recording academy
in the last couple weeks to perform at
the grammys and you don't perform at the
grammys if you're nominated for
nothing yeah he doesn't even have like a
single nomination yeah i don't even
think you got like an invite in the mail
no definitely not that's crazy very
bizarre
and then justin bieber released a very
bizarre statement about
his being nominated he wanted to make it
very clear that he wasn't coming off
ungrateful he's just confused because
changes this album is you know tried and
true in r b album from the melodies to
the rhythm to the lyrics
and he was treated as uh pop he was put
in the pop categories
yes this was his statement to the
grammys i am flattered to be
acknowledged and appreciated for my
artistry i am very meticulous and
intentional about my music with that
being said i set out to make an r b
album changes was and is an r b album it
is not being acknowledged as an r b
album which is very strange to me
i grew up admiring r b music and wish to
make a project that would embody that
sound for this not to be put in that
category feels weird considering from
the chords to the melodies to the vocal
style all the way down to the hip-hop
drums that were chosen
it is undeniably unmistakably an r b
album to be clear i absolutely love pop
music it just wasn't what i set out to
make this time around
my gratitude for feeling respected for
my work remains and i'm honored to be
nominated either way
ariana grande wasn't nominated for
anything but she actually took the year
off right
yeah for the most part for the most part
she might have had like a best pop
vocal performance right somewhere you
know she did stuck with you i don't know
if that that's
not it um but what is so interesting i
just scroll down to the country section
and
best country album are you ready for
these nominees
i remember reading it and feeling
underwhelmed underwhelmed but it's all
aside from little big town it's all
females oh wow ladylike by ingrid andres
so good your life is a record by brandy
clark wild card by miranda lambert
never will by ashley mcbride ashley
mcbride i don't know if i've mentioned
this
maybe two three hundred times i've
recently joined the ashley mcbride team
and she is just so everything of the
story yeah she really just stick to the
one-night standards
she's so good so good so um well love
seeing
women in country thrive and i've always
felt that
the the men that they build up in
country are just like not it like
yeah they're like tropes of country
music like jason aldean
they're still like cheesy yeah they're
like they're
they're just like people who seem to be
so country but their songs are corny and
like yeah
i i hear you and i do think they're
talented people but they just become
like an industry within themselves 100
and it's like they release the same song
they lose like that heart of the country
so i think the women in country music
are constantly releasing better music
and living for the grammys for seeing
that love it well those are the grammy
nominees it will be
airing in january hosted by trevor noah
so
we'll see you then oh hopefully he
doesn't ruin it i just have come to like
really resent hosts do you know
i know it's like who's hosting i'm
scared like you know
i'm never going to be happy with the
host ever because it should be me
i'm kidding okay next up selena gomez's
fans express
outrage over save by the bell reboot
mocking her kidney transplant
this is so this is just not a story i
saw coming like
in any way in any way mostly because i
wasn't like from
like aware of say by the bell reboot me
neither it was airing
peacock original i feel like we always
talk about these reboots that are coming
but like we never get to the part where
they follow up right you know but
apparently it's on
peacock now and it had several
references to the spingers 2017 kidney
transplant
in one scene from the new series two c
two students at bayside high
are arguing about who gomez's transplant
donor was
right one of the girls like it was
justin bieber yeah so one person said i
know for a fact that selena gomez's
kidney donor was justin bieber's mom
god i wish i had my phone so i could
prove it and the other student responds
prove what you're an idiot it was demi
lovato's kidney they're best friends
like you and i were
by the way it was her friend francia
raisa okay first of all
literally everyone knows that i feel
like this is just bad writing
in another scene the words behind the
main character the words does selena
gomez even have a kidney
appear to be defeated on the walls in
the school's hallway
so this is just bizarre and i really
want to chalk this up to bad writing
because it feels like
an old person wrote this being like what
are the kids you know debating over
these days
and i feel like they were looking for
like a cliche pop culture debate like i
would consider like
what happened in the elevator with jay-z
and beyonce to be like one of the great
mysteries of our time
and i think that they were trying to
capture that essence like but nobody
thinks anything
like everyone knows that francia raisa
was the woman who donated
her kidney to selena gomez and like we
all moved
on from it so this is like just this is
so like this is
obvious like of peacock like hiring
writers to write a show about kids who
know nothing about kids
very true well peacock released a
statement saying we apologize it was
never our intention to make light of
selena's health
we have been in touch with her team and
will be making a donation to her charity
the selena gomez fund for lupus research
at usc
so bizarre like in so many ways and like
it's just
it's not funny like right i like you
know
i i hear if you want to make it a joke
that maybe is not going to rub everyone
the right way
it really has to be funny like it has to
be like
just outstandingly hilarious and this
was like not only not funny but like
kind of cringy
and super rude beyond it's not a good
it's not a good way to start off
it's not a good look for anyone involved
here i'm embarrassed it's not a good
look for the reboot like i think that
this could like ruin
yeah it's taking the reboot down i don't
know how good of a chance it stood like
to begin with i don't know if it's a
good show but like
this is bad for the whole reboot it's
just awful like i'm embarrassed for
absolutely everyone involved
not to be dramatic but like it's just
it's really embarrassing like no i know
literally you released a show nobody
talks about it except now they're
talking about like something really lame
you did and you have to [ __ ] release
an apology and make a donation like how
embarrassing for you
yeah i'm embarrassed as you should i'm
embarrassed
you should be maybe i should talk to
someone about how embarrassed i am you
should
is there something today's episode sorry
is brought to you by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or preventing you from
achieving your goals
well betterhelp is here and they will
assess your needs and match you with
your own
licensed professional therapist this is
you know the perfect time to get into
therapy i think i think a lot of people
are going through stuff
being at home this is just like not a
normal time we're all feeling our
feelings
and we can't leave our house so better
help is it's never been a better time to
get on better help
where you can start communicating with a
professional therapist in under 48 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not
self-help it is professional counseling
done securely online
there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available to you in many areas
the service is available worldwide for
clients you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor
where you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions
so you won't ever have to sit in in an
uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy
also given what's going on in the
pandemic the more you can stay home the
better and now you don't have to leave
your house to get professional help
betterhelp is committed to facilitating
great therapeutic matches so they make
it easy and free to change counselor
change counselors if you need it
everyone says like when you start
therapy like it's okay to like shop
around a bit so
i love that they make that easy because
sometimes in real life like that can be
a little uncomfortable
um it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available
betterhelp wants you to start living a
happier life today so many people have
been using betterhelp that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
so if our listeners of the morning toast
want to get 10 off your first month
go to betterhelp.com toast that's
betterhelp.com
toast for the morning toast listeners to
get 10 off the first month of better
help
again that's betterhelp.com toast check
it out it's
something everyone needs love it okay
next story this was a big story of the
weekend
um the fight between jake paul and nate
robinson nate robinson is saying he's
okay after the ugly jake paul knockout
okay that's good because
above all like homeboy was like hardcore
knocked out cold like
dead asleep on the floor and i was like
sometimes i've only watched a few of
these fights and i always end up like
wanting to cry because like someone's on
the floor like looking lifeless and it's
really sad
yeah former knicks player nate robinson
said he was doing okay after getting
knocked out
by jake paul less than two minutes into
the second round of his pro boxing debut
on saturday quote thank you to everyone
for all of the well wishes i'm
okay i appreciate that triller for the
opportunity as well as everyone that has
backed me during the fight
to my coaches trainers fans and
teammates i appreciate all the time and
support you guys put in with me
so i i brought this up to you about
wanting to talk about it and there's so
many things i want to talk about go for
it
the first is this was like a mike tyson
fight so it was like really
legit but there were a few things that
made the whole evening like seem really
illegitimate to me trailer
the first being triller which is a tick
tock rival app
they spend like a lot of money on like
those hype house kids like they
they literally put them on like this
mansion like they pay for everything in
their lives just for them to like be on
triller too
like post their tick tock content on
triller like it's so weird i don't even
get the app
and now i guess they're like a wrestling
platform i have no idea i didn't get it
whatsoever
so for at first i'm like oh ben was like
the fight is on i'm like who's like mike
tyson i'm like oh that's legit
and then he's like yeah it's triller and
i'm like what and then he said
it's also another fight jake paul versus
nate robinson i'm like
okay this is becoming more illegitimate
with every with every
waking second and to me i found the jake
paul fight to be so much more
interesting than the mike tyson one
because first of all
it was a little embarrassing nate
robinson is a former professional
athlete and like jake paul is a viner
from ohio like
the two are not the same and jake paul
won like i just think that's worth
noting like
say what you want this has been such a
bizarre year especially for jake paul
like
his home got raided by the fbi and like
now he's out here winning pay-per-view
fights
and i don't know i was like really
rooting for him i bet 200 i bet 210
on jake paul to win a hundred dollars
and i won that's so exciting yeah it was
very exciting
i just like i wanted to root for the
youtuber you know like yes no this is
really at its core an exciting moment
for influencers
for content creators 100 and i just i
thought there were so many things that
were so interesting
about the evening obviously jake paul
being one of them and just like i've
been
now like following on social media like
his brother and tana like all them
celebrating
and i don't know like i know we're
supposed to hate the paul brothers but
like i just can't quit them like i just
like i'm
always like secretly rooting for them do
you know what i mean yeah no this was
interesting i had no i
like zach told me there was a fight do i
want to watch i was like no he was like
it's pop culture and i was like
no um and then i spoke to you and you're
like jake paul is fighting and i'm like
why don't you tell me jake paul was
fighting no it's crazy
yeah it was crazy i still didn't watch
it but um it definitely made it more
interesting
yeah no i watched it and like jake paul
like really won like fair and square
like
didn't even use all the rounds because
he got knocked out and uh
nate robinson like couldn't even stand
up let alone fight back like it was
crazy have you been still watching
filthy rich no
because um in the last episode second to
last episode
there's a fight like and he's like a
warrior for jesus oh it's a physical
fight oh
he gets in a you know maybe don't tell
me maybe i won't but just it's funny
that like the network that they're
calling it like part of sunny club where
they have a fight channel is called
praise purview wait that's so funny and
i didn't know that they had a pr a
pay-per-view channel like for fighting
well they they created one oh for him
for him yeah oh i love that
it's honestly it's just a show about
cancer no you know what as i'm watching
more i can believe it and it's honestly
like
it's not good no i know no it's like
really not good it's
it makes no sense no i know sometimes
you get like especially with these types
of shows like you get so distracted by
like
the great cast the fabulous location
the rich home the business the
billionaires like dynasty like when you
take all the fabulousness out of dynasty
like it's really not a very good show
but it's so
[ __ ] fabulous it's so good and i also
think that dynasty is really good
writers
yes and there's something about filthy
rich that's like so cheesy
no and like nothing makes sense like a
character does something i'm like
what is this that's not who this person
is or who this person's supposed to be
right like you guys logically ginger
sweets would have never turned down that
initial six million dollars remember
like
she she would have taken that money a
hundred percent yeah
and it's really at the end of the day
it's like bruno sweets over ginger
suites
always and that's where i land always
meet too me too
okay a little exciting tv
trivia game show news this is a two-part
story
the first one is that champion ken
jennings will be the interim jeopardy
host
yes i feel like this is most likely a
permanent decision but they have to see
how he does like
yeah will he be terrible who knows it's
always good to have a little test run
yeah i think i i like this you know it's
so the obvious choice and
even though other people were throwing
out like really decent recommendations
if they're not like connected to the the
history and the
memory of alex trebek then i just don't
think it's gonna work
yes so jeopardy is saying that ken
jennings will be the first interim guest
for the late alex trebek and the show
will try other guest hosts before naming
a permanent replacement so it's really
like
a competition yeah and like ken jennings
if you're listening the opportunity like
it's in your reach so just like don't
[ __ ] this up
yeah just just be yourself but
better more refined so it'll be
it'll be interesting to watch a little
other
game show trivia news that i find to be
quite interesting
chef david chang becomes the first
celebrity to win 1 million dollars on
who wants to be a millionaire
what charity did the celebrities don't
win the money themselves they win it for
charity and he won it for the southern
smoke
foundation oh by the way this episode i
started to watch last week
you know who wants to be like be a
millionaire it's like the worst show
ever because
like so it's an hour-long episode and if
somebody gets out 30 minutes in
they'll bring on another person and the
episode could be over and the person is
still in the middle of the game
yeah so when i was talking about who
wants to be a millionaire like last week
or the week before
watching this episode yeah and the
second half was his
he just had gotten started got it he's
friends with jimmy kimmel that's how we
got on the show
got it okay well here's the one million
dollar question let's see if we can get
oh okay
although he and his wife never touched a
light switch for fear of being shocked
who was the first president to have
electricity in the white house
[ __ ] you know i don't even know when
electricity was invented like
here are the options okay ulysses s
grant i didn't
who the [ __ ] is that benj he's the
general give yeah for sure grant
benjamin harrison that's not a president
no i know benjamin harrison
chester a arthur he's definitely
presidential vibes
andrew johnson he is the president okay
started
read the question again although he and
his wife never touched a light switch
for fear of being shocked okay so like
who were the conspiracy theorists in the
white house
who was the first president to have
electricity in the white house
so it must have been like a very new
thing although he and his wife
nevertheless no the answers
okay ulysses s grant benjamin harrison
okay chester a arthur
andrew johnson let's talk this through
okay and i'm really about to show how
dumb i am but
grant was civil war post-civil war so
like
when what year was the civil war um in
the 1860s
okay so that could be one electricity i
actually am going to vote ulysses s
grant i
i just have to take benjamin harrison
out of the running because like i truly
have never heard of him and i'm like 90
sure that this is like a trick question
because he was never actually president
um
andrew johnson
andrew johnson yeah i just i'm not
getting the vibe
you're not getting the vibe do you know
the answer no i don't
yeah i want to go just because i want to
go grant
okay ulysses for the win i'm going grant
he let's see what it is hold on
he said this was his like when he was
answering he said this is terrifying
oh about sorry never mind okay what's
the function
is girl
i don't know i don't know hold on we
might have to watch the clip
just google it like copy and paste and
google it okay well the suspense
the suspense it's killing me oh he he
phoned a friend
oh his pal espn anchor mina kimes
okay what's the answer
of course it is benjamin harrison are
you [ __ ] kidding me
you know i was actually thinking when i
was watching um who wants to be a
millionaire last week
that if i had to phone a friend or not
phone a friend but they let you have
like a compadre like
sit next to you in this new version i
would definitely bring you oh thanks
would you bring me a stink
we'd get like our own spin-off show
because we were like so funny you know
yeah we can dream yeah um well that's
exciting for him and the charity that
he uh it is exciting i think it's a
really cool idea i want
like having celebrities one who wants to
be a millionaire and it still is a hard
game to win so it's
very impressive celebrity versions of
like traditional game shows are always
good like celebrity family feud is so
good yes i agree i just love seeing
celebrities in like
weird situations like non-traditional
celebrity activities like
not red carpets or like movies like just
like weird everyday things you know
yeah now i need to look up like when
benjamin harrison was president like
1891 oh and when was ulysses s grant
it's just like there's really not that
many presidents like to not have ever
even heard of one of them just like
sounds crazy to me like
how irrelevant was he like i bet he
1869. so we were right in our like
civil war timeline but electricity was
just a little slower than that
that's just crazy okay okay fifth and
final story which is going to lead us
into a recap of the undoing
but grace frazier's costume designer
should be shot no kidding i'm kidding
but like what did she do
is speaking out about her wardrobe she
defending herself because she should be
so her name is yeah no that was like the
one piece of the puzzle that didn't
really fit for me so i was very
interested in this article that you sent
me where
um the costume designer explains herself
explains herself her name because
you texted me i got jackie to watch the
show and you text me like the show was
really good oh my god you guys this text
was so funny i said
this unbeaten is a really great show but
it would be better if nicole kidman
was dressed if her outfits were on point
and then literally we both texted at the
same time i said
she dresses like a witch and you said
why does she dress like
pocus you know and it's so true like the
big long green
duster that green coat is gonna haunt my
dream and she did look fabulous at that
school fundraiser and i thought that we
were starting and i thought she was
gonna be like this fabulous woman when
she goes to court with the business
suits
sylvia her friend had a better wardrobe
no i totally agree i just didn't
understand
the the thought behind it and here is
the thought
from the costume designer sidney
sedgeland who's based in copenhagen
she said that she wanted her vision for
grace's style to be hinged on two
somewhat contradictory ideas
quote i wanted her to be able to walk
around new york and stand out and blend
in at the same time she said
the latter of which is certainly more
ideal for someone entangled in a
gruesome murder case like grace's
yeah that also didn't make sense like
she's obviously such a visible person
in new york and in her community like
why would she be walking around in like
the brightest
greatest coach i know the coat was so
bad and
i do agree it did like take away from
this the show a little bit
because i thought like the way they
captured like that upper east side like
kind of
you know upper class like i thought it
was just excellent the apartments were
so stunning
and that school and all the other moms
like i really thought it was very well
done
and it was the one piece of the puzzle
that didn't didn't fit and and so she
said that she attributed grace's um
distinct style to her 70s uh like 70s
inside
inspired bohemian style because it's
something completely new for fans to see
nicole wearing on screen
contrasting celeste right yeah no but
like just because celeste had a great
neutral wardrobe doesn't mean
that grace should suffer yeah and at
first i thought that she was dressing
weirdly for them to try to convey like
she wasn't a regular upper east side mom
she was a cool mom that's what i thought
like maybe she had this like bohemian
style to reflect the fact that she was
um like a bohemian out-of-the-box
thinker yeah and their apartment was
like a little quirky with the purple
walls like
i thought maybe that was the point yeah
but like that wallpaper in the bedroom
that was like so upper east side yeah
and i just think that the show like
would have been on another level if her
outfits were like sickening
sickening on point like doesn't even
have to be like stupid like chanel suits
no like courthouse chic
theory moment yeah these coats and like
i saw people
trying to be like what code is nicole
mckinnon going to wear tonight
[ __ ] ass no like you know like
publications like oh yeah
so nobody so we're on the edge of our
seats wondering everyone wants to know
who did it we want to know what code
no i have like no interest in knowing no
the person who made that coach be
ashamed of themselves
and it's like
as the story goes on it's like three
months from the time she's murdered to
the trial and i'm just like
so grateful that it's no longer winter
100 so she leaves the code at home
[Music]
[Laughter]
um but that does lead us into the recap
you actually watch the whole series
on saturday and sunday and obviously
there was so much hype and fanfare and
it's obviously a good
show but i do think like it was a little
there was just i
it just makes me realize like people are
desperate for content because hundreds
percent this was not big little lies no
no people were treating this like game
of thrones like yes
literally let's all get together and
watch just have a watch party let's talk
who do you think did it who is it
because we were all like who's going to
be thinking that the entire
world was watching last night if we
weren't so
bored this show wouldn't have garnered
the amount of fanfare that it would have
just
went on and it would have been good and
it's a good show and
and i'm not and it's always nice to have
a good piece of premium content
and i wasn't bothered by the ending at
all i i didn't feel let down by it i
thought it was very smart
but like you could have watched and as i
was watching the episodes i said this i
was like you could have watched episode
one
and maybe two because in two you find
out about the affair and then just the
last episode all the stuff in the middle
it's like
her like sitting around crying going
talking to someone else thinking crying
going bringing here talk to the sun cry
also go to the jail cry
well so i was definitely disappointed in
the ending because it was just like
we didn't get anywhere but at the same
time i think that
the point of the show and i'm not by any
means like an interpreter of the arts
but i think it was meant to be that this
journey we went on like feeling like
hugh grant definitely did it oh wait no
he definitely did not let's look around
and find someone else who did it it
couldn't have been him to
oh wait spoiler alert was definitely him
that's what nicole kidman went through
like we're supposed to be the whole
story was told from nicole kidman's
point of view and like we went on that
emotional rollercoaster with her too
that wasn't enough for me at the end
like when when he was driving on the
bridge i'm like
do something crash your car like give me
something he didn't do anything
he didn't jump off the bridge i thought
the kid might have gotten hurt there was
nothing like everyone was fine
right but that's also because from what
i understand because of his like
narcissist personality disorder like he
was never actually going to hurt himself
he just wanted all these got it got it
right
like the helicopters yeah caring about
him and i do think that they rip the
editing straight from annie
now let me explain let me explain if you
are familiar with annie you know the
scene where
um miss hannigan and rooster her brother
they take annie and they they kidnap her
and she climbs that thing
and at house warbucks they realize that
that annie's gone and they get in the
helicopter
and as rooster's ascending like the
railroad tracks they're trying to get
the helicopter to meet
annie and when grace and her dad were in
the helicopter and they're like going to
the bridge to try and
get the kidnapped child i'm like this is
just plagiarism no by the way
i see it when they were in the
helicopter like frantic looking for a
missing child i was like is this amy
wow you know i haven't seen any in so
long but you're totally right well thank
you so much and like i posted it on my
story and i
there's a couple of interviews who agree
with me and like thank you i feel so
seen but so many people were like
actually i voted what but now like
no you're right you know i definitely
see it yeah it just wasn't the climax in
any way like in terms of
tv quality drama suspense you know uh
cliffhanger plot twist we got out of
that
no but i do think that it was really
smart because it's like we just all
believe
we all we all and we all went on this
journey in our heads i came up with
the most brilliant theory that i spoke
about on the patreon last week
where i really thought i had figured out
the ending and it would have been and
that's what we're so used to in tv like
the most crazy twist endings that like
in reality make no [ __ ] sense
yeah that's how we're trained i really
thought that elena was the grandfather's
illegitimate daughter
and that he had her killed because she
was getting too close to nicole kidman
and hugh grant like that's what i
thought
yeah no it it just like it was just so
obvious and and i liked it it definitely
it's smart and it made you think think
and we went on that journey with nicole
kidman but i also felt like at times
i wasn't seeing the show from her point
of view because i felt like there were
things about her that we didn't know
like
when there was also that underlying
thing like did she do it is she
schizophrenic and she has multiple
personalities and we didn't know that
like we actually saw her do this
yeah and the detectives are like i feel
like she's hiding something like
they were pretty on point the whole time
what was she hiding yeah
why was she walking right there but also
i think that
that um hugh grant's lawyer who was like
amazing at her job
she did make some valid points about
like what what makes hugh grant a
suspect
versus elena's husband yeah they both
had like reasonable doubt or whatever
or uh circumstantial evidence yes
no i she was a great lawyer she made
compelling points
just enough to put the plant the seed of
doubt in the jurors minds because you
don't have to like convince them that it
was someone else but you just need to
convince them that it's possible it's
possible that it wasn't hugh graham
yes and they were and they were doing a
good job yeah i
you know i i was suspicious of that
blonde friend sylvia too but she ended
up being a real one she was such a real
one from the beginning i knew it i said
to zach i'm like that's a good friend
like she had the cab waiting
when grace was at school and everyone
was talking [ __ ] about her she's like
let's get in the car
and let's go yeah no she was a good
friend yeah and everyone doubted her and
like said that she was the sad book
yeah i know that she was a side chick
she was the sad [ __ ] what's that
oh that when he said he had two affairs
one was because they were both really
upset
and haley was like a sad [ __ ] oh yeah no
it was 100 sylvia
it's still jury's still out it still
could be i mean it's a limited series i
don't believe there's gonna be a season
two and i really don't need one
for a season two yeah um and i i liked
how it all ended i'm glad i got to
participate
but i just maybe if i had been like the
first person to see it i would be like
this is the best show everyone has to
watch it
yeah but by being the last person to see
it i'm like what are you guys talking
about i think collectively everyone was
like pretty uh
let down no but like i didn't think
there was anything wrong with the ending
i thought it was really
good i thought the ending was was great
like
i think it had been some far-fetched
ending like that just would have been
stupid i thought it was smart i really
think it was smart i'm saying the rest
of the show like episodes two through
five were so [ __ ] boring
technically unnecessary now knowing what
we know yeah yeah that's fair
um okay and also real housewives of
potomac and our tv recap segment which
is brought to you by the natural dog
company
we all love our pets especially here at
the morning toast we treat them like
human beings
and that's why we only care the best we
only want the best care for them
so if your dog has skin issues you'll
want to give him or her products from
the natural
dog company i mean i spoiled my dog he
has like better health care better skin
care better diet
like than anyone that i know and his
skin and his allergies are no exception
because when his allergies flare up he
can be very miserable
itchy licking parts of his body it's
kind of sick
um and it's so sad to watch him talk
like that so not talk like look i really
think he's a human being
i mean he is prove to me that he's not
85 of dogs have experienced skin
irritation in the form of hot spots
allergies or rashes but now there's real
relief that really works
for all these conditions your dog
struggles with true healing at last from
the natural dog company
their products heal and prevent itching
scratching and discomfort
if you use the skin and coat supplements
to treat from the inside
and for the outside of your dog use the
natural dog's skin sue their healing
balm
it works and it works fast sometimes
you'll see the relief in seconds
natural dog products are made with all
natural ingredients and are vet tested
vet approved and vet recommended their
plant-based all-natural ingredients
soothe allergies heal hot spots and dry
flaky patches of skin
and maintain healthy skin and fur
products made for almost all your dog's
needs from supplements to skin
paw and grooming products everything you
need to keep your dog healthy and happy
and as a special very limited time offer
for our listeners you can get 20
off your natural dog order natural dog
company order
that's right 20 off your entire order
just go to natural dog company dot com
slash toast to make sure you get twenty
percent off natural dog company dot com
slash toast again that's natural dog
company dot com slash toast for 20 off
our dogs deserve better and i can't
believe i'm even using the word dog it's
so disrespectful
i know but they have the most amazing
things but i got all these products for
little sweets like for his little paws
for irritations
and i'm just like i'm feeling good
having these things in my home it's nice
to take care of your loved ones
it really is okay real housewives of
potomac actually getting
pretty good i'm not gonna lie yeah i'm
feeling you know this has been a
transitional season for me like i feel
like i'm turnt on almost everyone i was
turned
on and now people i was turned on i just
love like yeah i really was not a huge
karen huger fan before this but i've
i've seen the light and the error my
ways yeah no she is
everything of the sort like and it makes
me so sad how the women disrespect her
and
especially giselle like i'm i'm [ __ ]
done with jesus and what's so crazy is
the women
you know team who like giselle robin
candice wendy like
they really really think they are so
right you know and like
even at the dinner the the dominatrix
dinner they were like
um you're on the wrong time you're on
the wrong team and it's like
they can't even see the fact that they
might be wrong let alone the fact that
they are completely wrong and it's like
watching and then reading twitter and
it's like every single person
agrees with the fact that like karen and
monique and ashley like are the queens
of the season and the other girls are
just like
out of control in in their thinking
it is so i wonder like if they've
realized
if they've seen the other side yet well
i feel like
a lot of the decisions you make as a
housewife on air are
as a result of how you think you'll come
off yeah and i think that a lot of like
especially like
robin and gisele who are taking this
like moral high ground over monique
i think that they're doing that
anticipating that the audience will
agree with them like that
they want to be on the right side of the
audience's opinion
yes plus i think that you know gisele i
think so many people love giselle she's
really a fan favorite and i think that
she thinks that if she takes this stance
that like the audience will we'll follow
we'll follow because there are some
people
in the househouse franchises who it's
like whatever they whatever side they're
on is the side that i'm on
and she thinks that she's that person
and she's not that person she's almost
always on the wrong side
but like we forgive her because she's so
great and everything of the sort but
she's quickly becoming nothing of the
sort no she's so mean
she's so mean and her commentary she's
just so sniped about everyone and
everything
she's so hypocritical you know like i
it's one thing to be mean when you're
perfect but like
she is just like throwing stones when
she lives in a glass house
himself and a really big one and one
that easily shatters yes
i'm just like and i don't care about her
and jamal anymore like it's crazy like
i really was obsessed with her and i
just completely turned on her
and i just think she's like so mean and
i i hope that
at the reunion maybe some of the women
start taking like you know backstabbing
a little bit because the audience is not
on their side like at all but who do you
think
is gonna back down from their position
like i don't see it's obviously not
gonna be candice it's not gonna be just
it's not gonna be wendy it's not gonna
be wendy and robin goes where giselle
goes so like you're stuck
we're stuck it's just like
i can't believe that the all the women
monique and candice like have not been
in the same room
i know it was so nice to see monique
again i missed her so much
she's just so fabulous so crazy to me i
was watching the last scene in portugal
when you know ashley says that she is
going to
be um really writing writing the
statement
and they like it's so illogical can it's
like how dare you how could you do this
to me and it's like
candace you had every right to sue
monique for what she did to you but like
to not expect that monique has that same
right to defend herself
is insane no it's literally a level of
delusion that i can't relate to so crazy
like obviously she's going to protect
herself
like you put her in this position you
took it to this place
and now it's here and now like if you
were and you're mad that she's just not
being like you're right i'm sorry take
me to jail if you
if you weren't prepared to like have a
legal battle then you don't take it to
court
the courts don't take it to court i'm
it's shocking
and i just have to say like all these
women who are being so mean to karen
about the
wig line and how it like makes no sense
that she's releasing a wig line and they
didn't know anything about it
first of all i don't know anything about
my friends businesses like you know what
i mean what she has to update you every
time she writes a deck like
it's so they're so [ __ ] mean like
first of all when she did ladam perfume
she
she told everyone about it too early and
then they the whole time they're like
where is that where is it
so this time she told them about it when
it was here she and it's
that's not good enough and i haven't
heard about it i'm saying like it
doesn't make sense for her to do wigs
like she's not the queen of wigs i have
to say there's something about
embarrassing yourself on tv so many
times and then really getting now i say
she probably has the best wigs in the
group
and she came from literally her wig
falling off at dinner and her like
hairline being so far back like
i would buy a wig from karen huger who
knows more about bad wigs versus good
wigs than karen 100
and why isn't they acting like it's so
crazy like both kenya
and um
marlo have hair care products housewives
in all over other cities have like hair
care skin care makeup
gisele's starting a makeup line nobody
thinks oh look at gizelle i haven't
heard about her makeup line in a while
oh i don't think i look at giselle i
want her foundation
no one thinks that so i think that's
weird yeah also when giselle was like
um [ __ ] but she was like another thing
from karen
what two things no i mean like why are
they just medicare for wanting to better
herself and like become a business woman
like
i don't know i don't karen can do
nothing right yeah
and not in the way that they want it
because she tried it being like
telling them from the onset and it was
like so much chalk of the dom and
where's the bottle there's nothing in it
it's water right and now she's like okay
i'll give it to you when it's good and
ready and it's like
this came out of nowhere like i didn't
have to say a lot of them looked really
good candice actually looked good in
that blonde wig they looked like high
quality [ __ ] like
100 i would buy one 100 100
they're just so disrespectful towards
her and i love the fact that like when
they
were in the at the party and i forget
what they were even talking about and
when oh
this really bothered me i'm sorry this
was it when they were talking about
karen's drinking
and it's always really bothered me like
if someone doesn't want to drink
they don't have to drink and if it's
because she's embarrassed about what she
said the last time she was drunk that's
an extremely legitimate reason not to
drink and it's also
a legitimate reason to not want to tell
people that you're marist like
and gisele being like just own up to the
fact that you're embarrassed about what
you said when you were drunk it's like
you're so mean i couldn't agree with you
so and they're so irrational
like of course she doesn't want to drink
around you she let her guard down it
came back a few episodes later the
things that she said
and this isn't a group where she feels
comfortable everyone is so mean to her
she learned her lesson
no i couldn't agree more first of all
and someone's drinking is nobody's
business i'm glad that karen said that
like if i don't want a drink that should
be okay with you guys i don't need a
reason i don't need an ulcer
yeah i don't need a note from my doctor
that i don't want to drink but her come
back to robin about her drinking
and by the way it's clear there's some
there's something more because michael
next week also says he knows something
about juan
yeah no when she was like when robin was
like are you worried about where you're
going to stay when you're drinking and
karen just whipped so she didn't even
miss it stutter
did not miss a beast like you should be
worried about what juan says when he's
drinking no it's
so [ __ ] true and robin was like take
this wig off
no it was such a fire come back and then
she just bounced the [ __ ] out of the
party
she had a few moments of fire coming
receive that
towards robin who just like needs to be
put in her place so hard
karen comes to the party the dominatrix
party where everyone is like dressing
wild and crazy and like they're making
fun of karen's outfit that she looks
like corella deville like
[ __ ] up obviously she no you're right
nobody respects she doesn't want to do
anything because she's the only one like
literally candace comes in in a full
garment it's like yes candice
dennis is half karen's age half no and
like
candace looked amazing ever i would
never have like sure there were some
outfits at the party that i i wasn't
thrilled with
most of them and i'm sorry dressing in
costume and like putting yourself out
there like that
like the last thing you want to hear
from me it just it like
it cuts me deep no i know i don't i know
so when robin was like you look like
corella davila
and you look like a hooker on the side
of the street but you don't hear me
saying nothing about that like
thank you no i couldn't agree more also
there was literally like i'm all for
making fun of someone when
they do something weird there was
nothing wrong with karen's outfit like
it was all black with the first doll she
looks great
anything like because she had a fur
collar she's cruella de vil like really
that's the best we're coming up with
limited like
no i i just i'm so with you i'm so i'm
so annoyed on on
me too especially when you're coming
through with hats like that
you know that's the thing it's like i'm
all for like poking fun at people but if
you're gonna poke fun like you have to
be iron-clad
like your business has to be good your
finances have to be good your marriage
has to be good your house has to be nice
and i'm sorry robin dixon has none of
those things no also
i'm all for poking fun at people here
and there when they do something that's
worthy of being poked out
consistently but every time karen opens
her mouth every time she shares with the
group
she's trying to be like open and honest
and they
just like make fun of her and they take
advantage of it it's so
cruel i agree no wonder who the [ __ ]
would one if i was karen i would not
want to drink like
ever no it's like okay i thought we were
cool i thought we could all hang but now
we're gonna like make it weird
great this is work for me i will just
use this show to do my job message
received message received like she got
the message she has received received
right and i'm glad that she left she
paid the bill [ __ ] you yeah that was so
good she was just really on one last
night i mean i can't believe
exactly where she's coming from like
these women they come from her like they
don't
she's an institution they have no
respect yeah um i did cringe at the
bathtub scene it was very tamara and
eddie but not nearly as bad
but like i loved that ray like took his
starter to take his clothes off and i
was like please let him shut the door
because like
he's an old man and like yeah he doesn't
need it no it's an office it looks good
and then like we hear karen's laughter
and it's like that's beautiful
yeah i'm happy like a moan stop
i mean i think that like tamara will
probably agree like that was one of her
biggest regrets like that scene was just
awful
yeah it's never a good place to be but
it's karen she's cute
yeah but you know a housewife is like
super desperate when they get to that
place yeah so i just hope that karen's
feeling good
yeah and i hope that things are going
better for her and ray and i just hope
like the reunion is transformative like
for karen for monique like for all these
things i hope like
robin gets with like she really needs i
hope giselle gets like called out on all
of her [ __ ]
candice like a little bit of your
hypocrisy is showing like i hope it
i hope that you know andy does does the
work
yeah no i i hope that he does it on
behalf of the fans because it really
seems like
this is how people feel yeah um but it
was actually it was a very good episode
and
uh season finale is next week and then
we have reunions so
i'm just looking forward to justice
being served always
it's always nice to see it happen yeah
reunion will be good is there anything
else you want to
say wrap up no chat um i mean i watch
like some
a lot of stuff oh folklore folklore very
good yeah no really well done um what
were someone like as the
like a member of the swifty code what
were some of the codes that you were
happy to on code
well that obviously one of the
songwriters on the songs was a guy named
william barry and it ended up being joe
alwyn her boyfriend
which is just crazy because she spoke a
lot about how like on three separate
songs like he literally wrote like the
verse in the chorus like i didn't even
know he could sing or play piano or
write music
yeah no shocking first shocking second
of all
what i really liked about the
documentary is like a lot of times you
know taylor's songwriting is like real
storytelling
so it's not hard to figure out what is
it what it's about but there's a few
songs that like a legit could not
understand like epiphany and hoax
um that made no sense to me and
hearing her explain them oh like it's so
obvious like yeah
the comparison about like what her
grandfather went through at some um
like he was in the war at some battle
like he never spoke about it because it
was so painful
it's like what she saw like healthcare
workers going through like how like some
of them are going to be traumatized
after this and like never be able to
talk about what happened
um that made sense but like at first
when i heard the song i'm like what is
this girl talking about
and then also getting new layers to a
lot of her songs like this is me trying
um which is such a good song and uh
i have so much more respect for it
because like that's how everyone feels
it's not just about like celebrity and
fame it's just like
i'm just trying to get by like help yeah
i really like that she gave a nice shout
out to carrie underwood when she was
talking about like country music
that was so funny so funny when she was
like that trope like that songwriting
like uh tool yeah where you're like
there was a man and he met a woman and
then they had me like i was dying and i
knew exactly what she's talking about
like songs like taking a picture
i carry underwater songs they paint a
picture and then like have this like
plot twist at the end and that's like
when you break the song and then it was
bought
by me it was so funny and i like hearing
her explain that like i just lived for
it because i totally knew what she was
talking about yeah no
that was pretty sweet the outfits were
just not working for me
but it's clear that like there is this
aesthetic for folklore and it's like
very grungy and it's just it's not my
favorite but
the outdoor look with the hat was good
it was good it was the best
of the looks but overall they were all
quite bad i guess
i don't get it i really was very
interested by aaron desner like he seems
like this
like a guy who has a lot of stories you
know and i think he was like
really shy it's his long pond he owns
the studio and the palm and the pond
that comes with it and
i like that's a man of taste to me yeah
and what i learned was that like he had
the track already made for peace and
like he just sent her this like weird
piece of music
because she was like send me like the
weirdest stuff you have and she wrote on
piece but like he had created that
beautiful pizza music they did that a
lot where he just like sent her
instrumentals and she put her stuff on
it yeah but
knowing that our destiner is the king of
peace
and hearing them talk about it was like
obviously it was like honestly emotional
for me like
i it was aaron desner is a true man of
taste
and we got a little cameo from um boney
bear
yes why was he wearing a mask uh he was
in his own house
oh i don't know maybe maybe there was a
person on with the camera
but he was singing like it was obviously
dubbed over because oh you think
there was like if you're singing in a
mask there's gonna be fuzz like oh i
thought it was really him
i think it was dubbed for sure no that's
a nice voice i also thought bony bear
was like
60. so um it was interesting to hear
he's like a contemporary
and c and he's like handsome yeah no but
and then he's like a new artist because
i was reading stuff about like past
grammy nominations and he won best new
artist like a few years ago yes
i like thought boney bear was you know
one of the great rock like idols of the
80s
i just really did yeah no he's like one
of us
no i thought he was like you know steven
tyler pony bear are you serious like led
zeppelin i mean i never thought about it
like too hard but if you had asked me
how old is bony bear i would have been
like oh
50 60. wow that's crazy yeah
i just like remember when i was in high
school he was like a young new guy so
like now
i was young then so we're like the same
age yeah no i i always
i also thought it was bon iver and i so
did everyone else yeah and it should be
and i thought that he was just like a
legend yeah the legend
of the rock was way hardcore i'm so glad
to have like clear that up for you
yeah no i mean taylor did but yeah i did
too
um you know it was great i'll definitely
be watching it again that's the type of
content we need in these dark times and
i really appreciate it it was very well
done
yeah any other interesting factoids were
there no jack antonoff
is just like so quirky you know what i
mean yeah
when he was performing august just like
vibing out so hard august is like pretty
much like the only
that and um the great last great
american dynasty are the only like
upbeat-ish songs and he was just like
vibing so hard like he was just excited
to like dance
yeah i have a question she was in la and
she made her like kitty committee studio
at home in her bedroom i don't know why
that was she said she was in la did she
yes she said she was in la during
quarantine
why didn't she just go to nashville
where she has a studio right doesn't she
have a studio in one of her homes
she must but um and did she have a plane
yeah it probably wasn't that hard to get
the studio set up and she was like happy
in l.a maybe like her family was there
she wanted to travel with her parents i
don't know
okay it just like seemed like i and
she's a studio in new york i understand
why she didn't want to come here but
she i don't know she doesn't have a
studio in new york that she did no
she films that she always records that
electric studio like where lady gaga
like walked out of the joann documentary
and those like denim undies
got it also i feel like her past few
albums it's like every heartbreak had
been about like you know
kanye and the cancellation and that
really like colored all of her
like writing experience and now it's
like all scooter braun and scott
like in everything she was saying when
she was like and this hurt and this like
pain i was like
when scott it's more so scott is the
betrayer because like he when she was
like you have a best friend who knows
exactly how to hurt you and then like
turns around and does that like she's
talking about scott because she has no
friendship
my tears ricochet is 100 about scott but
there were so many times when she was
explaining songs and she talks about the
betrayal and the pain or an experience
or a heartbreak
and it just feels like she's talking
about the big machine every time
every single time yeah i didn't really
realize how much the lakes is about
scooter broad oh my god so i'd only
heard the lakes once or twice and it
didn't really resonate with me but then
when she explained the song i was like
this is my song like where we move to a
[ __ ] take me to the lakes where all
the poets went to die and i don't belong
when you just leave it all and you go
live the farm champion
this line is like us those windermere
peaks look like the perfect
place to cry like that's what we need
like
we just need a peak to cry on no like
the lakes
that's that's me yeah you know it's such
a good song
and they did it that's what she said the
poets they did it they left
and they just did they like everyone
talks about sicily and they did the
thing that would make them happy still
working still doing their art
but you know in a little cottage with
some what's it called wisteria
yes on the like on the house yeah
yeah i agree um i thought and she said
like that's what
it's like the message of the whole album
is the lakes it was like the final song
so like and then that i'm sorry but like
that message that idea of like leaving
it all behind and
to end saying goodbye to the things that
make you unhappy and going to your happy
place like
that's the farm champion lifestyle and
like we just relate like she calls it
the lakes i call it farm chairman yeah
it's the same thing
100 no like and it's just this common
idea like we have so much in common
we truly and i really wouldn't i didn't
know that that we wouldn't have
understood it
no no i wouldn't i agree i think the
whole documentary gave me a brand new
appreciation for the lakes
100 um so it was excellent i highly
recommend it light a candle catch a vibe
yeah i didn't have any candles lit but i
still i had a few i caught the vibe
fabulous what else did you watch i
watched married at first sight i watched
season six
i stumbled upon it and it was like good
you know what it really is
it's love is blind really like you would
like it because it's
it's the same like so they pick two
people by matchmakers like there's a lot
of intention behind the two people that
they set up it's not really just like
raping someone and they go they have a
little wedding they go on their
honeymoon
they have to go and get an apartment
together and it's like six weeks it's
just like love is wine it really felt
the exact same
and this season was so good it was good
it was like the couples
there were some one couple that lasted
but one of the guys he was with this
girl who was just like
so so not nice to him and he was like
really really trying and she was just
like
being awful and i wanted to know
obviously they didn't they broke up
before even like
decision day and i wanted to know what
happened to each of them and i went to
his instagram
and he's like engaged to this woman who
has children i was like so happy for him
and as i'm like looking closer at the
photos it's her
the marriage counselor from the show oh
my god
and like she's so cute and they are so
happy together and i was like
all i wanted the whole time was for him
to just like find happiness it was
obviously not to be with this girl but
like there was another couple that was
on the rocks i'm like she he'd be good
with her like right i just wanted him to
be with someone
and see this journey for him wait that's
crazy i was so shook
that's crazy and that made the whole
season worth it totally totally
i've never watched it but people love it
yeah and you if you ever got around to
watching it you would like it because
it's like great reality tv content and
we love to see it
um it's just i know your content plate
is full so full yeah
um okay great well that sounds fabulous
and that was fabulous it was great
talking to you again great to see you
great to see you and tell cynthia my
love of course always
thank you guys so much for listening to
the morning bruno can go [ __ ] himself
millennial morning show we deliver the
best stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching us on youtube please
feel free to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up we're also
available as a podcast podcast anywhere
podcasts can be found so that's spotify
itunes stitcher public radio i already
cast blocks all the places wherever you
listen to podcasts find
us the morning chelsea leave a five-star
review about how beautiful stunning and
smart we are we hope you have an amazing
day you guys and we will see you
tomorrow
goodbye you'll get through it today just
keep your head up yep we got this
halfway done
you